how are you
hi
wow you guys said the premiere last
night claire you looked amazing in the
serpent dress tom you in a black suit
social media was going crazy they were
saying you you're aging like fine wine
that's all i read this morning so
congratulations to the both of you have
you even made the people sexiest man
alive list yet like people are going
crazy over you it's insane
there we go i'm blushing
[Laughter]
how was it for you guys did you guys
have fun with family and friends are you
excited for people to see the series
yes it was really it was wonderful it
was really um
to be back in with with our
essex serpent team was really been a
while and and it was lovely to
to watch it and and
yeah and do so maskless actually yeah um
it was kind of wonderful to be able to
celebrate
um
uh fully exposed um
yeah that was quite unvaccinated
right
and i love the story about cora um
claire you did a fantastic job bringing
her to life and i read this book too and
uh one of the things about her is that
she's from an abusive relationship she's
trying to find her independence at a
time when women are not allowed but i'm
curious to know what did you learn about
cora that you found intriguing
well actually i i
um was really interested in that
transition from her kind of um kind of
gilded cage into the
um
kind of unfenced
world and it's
she's
pretty clumsy and kind of unaware of her
edges and
does cause harm
yeah totally unintentionally in in the
process so um you know kind of charting
that was
challenging but uh um
but but really fascinating and um
you know i i i was really happy to play
somebody who
um
sort of
had been
overwhelmed by a sense of
uh
shame that she
learned was
unearned uh and was able to
uh kind of free herself from through
many different forms of love
and it was really prism-like you know
it's i mean obviously the great romance
is with will but
actually her platonic romance with
martha is as rich and vital
um
[Music]
you know and essential to her
uh well-being and ultimate you know
integration
well said and will doesn't believe in
the mythical creature what does the
serpent represent to will
well yes i think initially this the idea
of the serpent is very dangerous because
it threatens to destabilize
the whole community um
so will's trying to contain
these anxieties but
i think this the serpent is a
a kind of symbol of
something deep that is not yet known and
has not yet been understood
and
and maybe will's certainties
been challenged until
cora's arrival and
new depths and new dimensions to life um
are awakened by her and invigorated by
her curiosity and her intellect and her
passion
and
i think it takes him by surprise and
takes them all by surprise i think
so
but there's a
i suppose this idea of the serpent as
being something deep that is not yet
known yeah
is applicable to every character
um
it's applicable to stella
will's
wife and and to luke dr luke garrett the
young
surgeon and
to martha and to their children they're
you know the
it's interesting the children in the
story are the ones who who are the most
fervent believers in the serpent and of
course they're on the
they're on the precipice of adulthood as
well
and so it's um a serpent is a kind of
life symbol
uh life symbol yeah
and since we live in a mythical world if
loki came into battle with the serpent
who would win
i think well i've got to put my chips on
loki right i've ever just got
yeah
he's also a shape-shifter so he may
choose to transform himself into a snake
there's a moment in ragnarok thor
ragnarok where uh thor tells a story
about being um
mistaken he runs into a snake and it's
in fact loki
so yeah the serpent hasn't got a chance
he doesn't have a chance congratulations
to both of you i'm getting wrapped but
it is an incredible series thank you for
making i really appreciate it